hey conan you popped up on saturday
night live very recently and very
especially yeah yeah it was uh
especially yeah especially i don't know
if that's the right way
it was a very special episode of
saturday night live where they
they they addressed eating disorders and
it started off by saying this is a very
special saturday night live tonight
especially what am i thinking i don't
know what you were thinking but um
yeah it was really nice uh it was
especially i don't know when this
when this when people will be hearing
this but um as i speak it was just the
other day uh and
what happened was uh john mulaney who
i'm a huge fan of and we've become pals
over the years uh he
basically
told me that he was me hosting uh
saturday night live for the fifth time
and that i was invited to
come by and see the show
and i had not been back to um 30
rockefeller center i know
pretty much since uh you know i i
departed in 2009 to come out west so i
hadn't been back there
and
it felt like this is a nice way to go
back the plan was just for me to
sit in the audience and get to see some
of the people that i've you know or hang
around backstage and watch the show
and then um
and and reconnect with people like jim
downey who's the head
was the head writer at saturday night
live uh who hired me who's one of the
icons one of the great comedy writers of
all time he and i have reconnected
recently so i was going to see him and
we were going to see the show together
and uh watch john
do his thing and then john mentioned to
me he called me up i think it was on
thursday or something and said hey we're
writing a sketch would you want to be in
it and i thought uh if i get paid uh oh
no i didn't i said uh i i said sure and
it was what was nice about it was i
always like whenever i can close a
circle or in this sort of cosmic way
there's a sketch called five-timers club
and uh it's basically any time someone's
hosted the show
their fifth time they they're
welcomed into the club a long time ago i
think this was 1989 maybe or 1990 when i
was a writer at snl they did the sketch
for the first time someone thought of it
and they were welcoming
tom hanks into the five-timers club
and i'm just a writer at the show a
skinny kid in his 20s i remember jim
downey i think said
well there should be a doorman who opens
people up who opens the door and lets
people into the club conan why don't you
do that and uh so there's this footage
you can probably see online of
of the very first five-timer sketch from
whatever it is 90 or you know i saw that
was that the first time you were on
camera no i had done other things but
this was a big one just because
steve martin's in the sketch and elliot
gould's in the sketch and uh paul
simon's in the sketch
and uh uh my job was was just to open
the door and i think tom hanks
unnecessarily says a fake name for me he
says oh hello sean like there was no
reason for me to have a name but i think
he just said oh hello sean
and it's like
and then i put a smoking jacket on him i
remember this having a little trouble
with the smoking jacket for a second uh
and and having a heart attack um
i think probably nobody else remembered
yeah
and then i remember seeing this live
yeah i watched that and did you did you
look at the guy who was opening the door
who worked at the five-timers club named
sean and think that guy looks like he's
got what it takes no i thought that guy
will someday be the bane of my existence
a lot of people thought that and they
were right so anyway i did that and it
was kind of just a nice moment you know
of all the moments in my life that was
just a nice little moment that i had so
then um
john mulaney very kindly uh
said oh it'd be kind of cool if conan
was in this five-timer sketch and
uh came by and he gave us the reason
when they asked me what are you doing
here i said i'm here to sign up for
peacock uh
that was great
but uh and then you know sir john wrote
this nice thing and i thought well this
is okay this will be fun and then i come
back to nbc and i hadn't been there in a
long time and uh it was just lovely
because
all these
cameramen
i mean blai you can jump in here because
aaron blair you worked with me at
saturday and not at saturday night live
you worked with me at late night which
was on the ninth yep uh we were on the
ninth floor and snl was on the eighth
floor
um and their offices are on the 17th
floor uh i'm just going to start naming
yeah keep telling us
then there's an insurance company on the
fifth floor and you walk in from the
front door our studio of course on the
sixth floor no anyway uh yeah it's
floors with conan o'brien yes jesus
now on the 43rd floor it's interesting
there's a bitcoin company now uh
but anyway you work there blai and and
so there are all these people
that have
worked at 30 rock forever and so you go
there and people are just coming off of
it's nice have you ever seen the movie
sunset boulevard
there's a scene where
nora desmond the aging silent film star
goes back to the studio and she goes
back to the film studio and she hasn't
been there in a long time and she walks
in and all these people up in the
cameras and holding the lights go nora
nora you know it's me and she goes oh
giuseppe you know and then another guy
will go like miss desmond you know good
to see you and you go oh it's you know
it's uh it's tommy hello there tommy
that's how it felt a little bit i was a
very old silent film star
who went back but it was it was really
um very meaningful and sweet because uh
some of the people that worked on my
late night show are there
tina ryan who did you know worked in uh
in wardrobe she came and found me and
started
she was crying and i practically started
crying although i didn't because i don't
have uh uh well i don't have a soul
but uh we had a really nice connection
and uh so many people came out and said
hi
and
i
absolutely loved it it and and then
to boot i get to i don't take it for
granted but anytime i get to hang out
because you really do have to hang out
there for a while um if you're doing it
you have to do it at dress you have to
do it at air so
who am i hanging out with tina fey
steve martin you know candice bergen was
in the sketch and elliott gould and uh
you know paul rudd who you know it's one
of those things where you'd love to be
able to say you know the way you think
paul rudd is a nice guy well let me tell
you and then you you he is
there is not a nicer human being in the
world than paul rudd and he's really
funny obviously and great so
i was just having the time of my life
hanging out with these guys you
mentioned the podcast oh yeah that was
no that was disparagingly despairing
disparagingly yeah well they had this
great setup line which was you know i
basically say john mullaney this is a
very special thing why i host you know i
i you know i was on tv for whatever 30
years and and i can
now you know i i think i'm bragging or
somewhat about how i've been on tv for
30 years and then he said or for decades
and he's and then he says well what do
you do now and i just went i have a
podcast and um
and uh and getting to just hang out with
such
you know i mean these are
it's funny because people assume that
because i've been doing this a long time
that i wouldn't get phased by people but
i'm always going to be a little
intimidated by a steve martin and and
frankly also with tina fey i think she's
absolutely brilliant and uh every time
i'm around tina i'm like i'm on my best
behavior because
i uh you know she's uh one of the best
of all time and and i just so anyway
that was all great but was really funny
as i make that kind of joke about yeah
i'm just doing a podcast big deal ha and
the crowd really laughs and then i'm
walking when the sketch is over and the
band's playing you have to walk through
the crowd to get back to your dressing
room and people in the crowd started
shouting
and i was turning around
yeah it was so funny because i've just
been like oh i just have a podcast and
then i'm walking through that crowd and
those chairs are on the floor and a guy
goes catechin and then someone else goes
karakai and then someone else is like
has god made her and i'm like man my god
yeah this is great
and then they uh yeah so that was
i mean and then i of course i went to
the after party and uh talked to lauren
michaels for a really long time which
was
he's the reason anybody knows me at all
he put me he plucked me from pretty much
complete obscurity and put me in this
impossible position so that was uh
anytime i you know i get to pass cross
paths with him and sit there and have a
drink and and and talk is really
a big deal for me and then
and also getting to talk to that cast
and those writers uh they're super
talented and so it it just was kind of
emotional you know to to get to go back
and have that connection
and also just see what good hands that
show is in i mean they're they're very
very man they're talented writers and
incredibly talented performers so anyway
that was a treat very cool